[Musique]
et cette invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
à la Wang bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur
ce plateau merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation vous êtes cinélo sinologue en
signant à l'École Centrale le dernier
ouvrage auquel vous avez participé le
dossier chinois portrait d'un pays au
bord de l'abîme au Cherche Midi pourtant
l'abîme est loin en tout cas on
apparence ces dernières heures à la
mangue à Pékin où cette ouvert le 20e
congrès du Parti communiste au Palais du
Peuple moment important de la vie
politique chinoise à l'issue duquel si
Jean pin devrait obtenir un troisième
mandat de 5 ans à la tête du parti et
donc du pays lui qui est déjà au pouvoir
depuis 2012 cette réélection
reconduction n'est pas véritablement
l'enjeu du Congrès tant elle est acquise
quel est l'enjeu si ce n'est pas ça
alors quand même un petit enjeu oui il a
quand même cette obéit obligation de
passer par ce congrès du parti et
ensuite en mars par l'Assemblée
nationale populaire pour redevenir
président la République donc non il est
quand même obligé de passer par tout ça
maintenant l'enjeu évidemment c'est pour
lui de poursuivre son rêve on parle de
rêve chinois c'est-à-dire l'idée de
faire de la Chine en 2049 la première
puissance mondiale et donc surtout
d'avoir l'adhésion évidemment de
l'ensemble de la population et de
l'ensemble des membres du parti ce qui
n'est pas forcément acquis alors
précisément comment peut-il encore plus
consolider sa toute puissance et a-t-il
si Jean pin au sein du parti des voies
discordantes est-ce qu'elles peuvent se
faire entendre alors il y a eu récemment
des voies discordantes avec les on va
dire les plus anciens du régime on parle
souvent de monsieur sempping qui a 150
qui est sorti un petit peu on va dire de
chez lui en disant bon maintenant
faudrait peut-être revenir à la réforme
économique California et à l'ouverture
de la Chine qui avait mis en place
dencia opening on sent que et
véritablement depuis l'arrivée de Simply
en 2012 on est dans un face à quelqu'un
qui a repris tout en main toutes
l'économie éliminer on va dire vivre
toute tout ce qu'il y avait au niveau de
la société civile les personnes qui
essayent de faire avancer un petit peu
le système vers un peu plus de
démocratie donc évidemment il a ces
gens-là sont peut-être endormis pour le
moment mais on peut penser quand même
qu'il y a des forces de pression à
l'intérieur du pays qui risque de
remonter petit à petit parce que pour
bien comprendre ce qu'il se joue il faut
peut-être que vous nous expliquiez
comment s'organise la détention du
pouvoir en Chine elle était peut-être
plus collégiale jusqu'ici tant et là si
Jean pin a tendance à l'individualiser
alors c'est à dire que pendant un
certain temps le dexiapine justement où
les dirigeants de l'époque avaient peur
justement d'avoir un potentat enfin un
dictateur en place qui est difficilement
remplaçable le jour où il meurt alors si
si zimping là est parti on pense quand
même pour un certain nombre de mandats
de toute façon il fera certainement
comme mode donc comme dexiapine gardera
la commission militaire à sa main ce qui
fait que évidemment le jour où il va
disparaître qui sera nommé à sa place et
là on voit très très bien pour l'instant
alors on verra ça dimanche mais pour
l'instant qu'il n'a pas de successeur
nommé donc je suppose que au moment où
il va disparaître s'il n'a pas fait ce
travail on va se retrouver comme en 1960
1976 à la mort de Mao avec un parti qui
va être déséquilibré à chercher qui
pourrait prendre la place de simping
plus tard donc il a fait changer la
Constitution en 2018 alors il commence
tôt 2012 il commence à modifier un peu
les choses en introduisant dans la
charte du parti et dans la Constitution
chinoise un peu de sa pensée la pensée
comme on a eu la pensée mood the Dong et
donc c'est à partir de ce moment-là au
petit à petit il va tout reprendre en
main en créant des groupes dirigeants
qu'on me dirigeants qui fait que bon sur
l'armée enfin sur tous les domaines à la
tête desquels il est toujours là
c'est-à-dire il squeeze complètement
tous les ministères on a tout ce qui
avait été mis en place précédemment et
là en théorie grâce à cette changement
ce changement de Constitution pour le
coup qui a été officialisé je crois en
2018 en théorie il peut rester président
à vie alors en théorie il peut rester
président à vie de toute façon
maintenant la présidence ou le manière
générale comme précédemment c'est pas
forcément ça qui est le plus important
le plus important c'est de décider à la
tête de la commission militaire il a
nettoyé l'armée il a mis des gens à lui
au plus haut niveau donc c'est quand
même un organe maintenant qu'il qui va
qu'il domine et qui va être utilisé
forcément à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur pour continuer à sur son
pouvoir il pourrait être le dirigeant
dit-on le puits puissant depuis Mao le
fondateur du régime qu'est-ce qu'il
incarne aujourd'hui c'est gin pour les
pour les Chinois alors qu'est-ce qu'il
incarne alors il a il joue beaucoup sur
le la fibre nationaliste c'est-à-dire
une opposition à l'Occident une
opposition je dirais ce que l'Occident a
mis en place depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et donc de de
de dire que la Chine est en train de
renaître c'est la renaissance de la
Chine et donc une Chine qui doit
forcément demain être la première
puissance du monde ça c'est peut-être ce
qui peut-être le peu le plus le porter
maintenant je dirais depuis ces son
dernier quinquennat on a quand même vu
que il a il a force il a fortement
restreint la liberté de de comment dire
de l'économie privée et donc je pense
que de ce côté là à l'intérieur que ce
soit dans la tech avec des gens comme
Jacquemin ou dans dans d'autres domaines
évidemment les gens sont plutôt
on va dire pas en opposition ouverte
mais évidemment toucher fortement et
puis il y a 0 covid on parle très peu du
zéro covid mais c'est une politique qui
a mis la Chine je dirais économiquement
véritablement dans une situation très
difficile aujourd'hui et puis qui a été
socialement et qu'il est toujours
socialement extrêmement dur à ce point
qu'on a entendu chose assez rare des
voix se faire entendre pour critiquer
cette politique zéro covid est-ce que
l'impulsion qu'il a donné ces dernières
heures notamment dans son discours
d'ouverture du congrès on peut laisser
penser que cette cette dureté va se
poursuivre alors oui et non oui d'une
certaine façon il est obligé de le poser
comme ça en ce moment parce que sinon ça
veut dire qu'il renierait pratiquement
trois ans de politique extrêmement dur
de l'autre côté s'il veut faire
redémarrer l'économie chinoise il va te
voir libérer les choses on voit très
très bien la difficulté qu'aujourd'hui
les entreprises étrangères qui
travaillent en Chine donc beaucoup sont
en train de de quitter le territoire
chinois on voit la difficulté les
faillites de nombreux Chinois dans
toutes les villes qui ont été confinées
alors pas dire tout le pays est confiné
mais si on compte actuellement on est
entre 65 et 100 millions de personnes
qui sont confinées à travers le pays ce
qui est énorme ce qui est plus que la
population française contrairement à ce
que c'est d'une pin dit de lui-même et
de son sa façon d'exercer le pouvoir il
parle de miracle ça ne va pas si bien
que ça en Chine la croissance économique
est en berne je crois que c'est la plus
basse croissance à cette année sera la
plus basse croissance que la Chine est
fait depuis les années 90 on va dire
depuis véritablement le démarrage réel
de la de la réforme économique donc ça
va ça va pas bien du tout et en plus je
pense qu'avec la la confrontation avec
les États-Unis sur le plan des semis
conducteurs par exemple
l'économie chinoise va être encore être
touché beaucoup plus durement puisqu'il
a depuis pas mal d'années essayez de
mettre en place une Chine
technologiquement à la tête du monde et
de décider de nous fournir de nouveaux
produits on parle beaucoup de la voiture
électrique ces jours-ci avec le salon à
Paris mais évidemment sans
semi-conducteur de nouvelles générations
les voitures électriques chinoises vont
être vite dépassées et est-ce que ça
pour le coup cette fragilité relative
économique de la Chine bien sûr c'est
taux de croissance font rêver en
Occident mais dans son histoire récente
c'est effectivement plutôt en berne
est-ce que ça pour le coup ça pourrait
le fragiliser au sein du parti ah oui
évidemment plus que des questions dans
le social il y a aussi quand même on
parle peu du côté humain mais il faut
voir aussi que ce qui se passe au
cimetiang ce qui a été dénoncé à travers
le rapport de Madame bachel l'Onu la
répression des vigours la répression qui
s'est engagée à nouveau au Tibet la
répression sur la société civile
chinoise etc c'est quand même je dirais
à l'extérieur très mal perçu et à
l'intérieur évidemment sur le point de
la société civile on sent aussi que moi
il y a des gens qui aimeraient bien
s'exprimer on l'a vu récemment avec
quelqu'un qui a accroché une banderole
réclamant la liberté donc je veux dire
qu'il y a quand même faut pas voir non
plus la Chine comme étant un glacis à
l'intérieur ça bouge alors est-ce qu'il
arrivera dans les temps à venir
véritablement contrôler tout ce qui est
en train de de de bouger je ne sais pas
ça c'est une question
[Musique]
d'ouverture du congrès il a affirmé dans
lequel il y avait assez peu de surprises
sémantique il l'a affirmé que son pays
la Chine se tenait du bon côté de
l'histoire d'un point de vue chinois
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire alors le bon
côté de l'histoire pour la Chine c'est
qu'elle sort on va dire après on va dire
la colonisation clientèle pour nous
1850 la deuxième la guerre comment dire
la guerre civile on a une Chine qui
aujourd'hui depuis les années 2008 2007
pense que véritablement son heure de
redevenir la grande puissance du monde
est revenue parce qu'il y ait les crises
économiques les subprimes la crise des
tests souveraines en Europe et donc on
est on est dans un esprit ou
véritablement aujourd'hui il est en
train de dire la Chine est à nouveau
enfin est en train de redevenir la
grande puissance qu'elle a été avant son
contact on va dire colonial avec l'oxyde
avec l'Occident et est-ce que ça
pourrait aller jusqu'à une guerre dans
les années à venir avec Taïwan par
exemple alors Taïwan pour le pour le
Parti communiste chinois enfin pour la
pour la République populaire de Chine
fait partie intégrante sur le plan de
son territoire de la Chine donc est-ce
que ça peut faire est-ce que il le dit
dans son discours il dit si je peux le
faire passer physiquement je le ferai
pacifiquement mais si je dois utiliser
la force j'utiliserai la force donc
évidemment dans ce cas-là on peut
toujours se dire qu'à tout moment pour
une raison pour une autre admettons qui
est des des des problèmes à l'intérieur
du pays on va dire politique important
au sein du parti ou même sur le plan de
la société civile qu'est-ce qui va se
passer il peut utiliser le fait de
reprendre Taïwan comme un élément
nationaliste pour essayer de souder
derrière lui une grande partie de la
population donc on peut avoir ce genre
de de scénario maintenant évidemment il
a plutôt intérêt pour le moment vu ce
qui se passe avec Poutine en Ukraine de
faire très très attention dans une
démarche derrière mais les États-Unis
surveille de très près ce qui se passe
dans la région
ils apportent aussi de l'armement je
veux dire c'est quand même aujourd'hui
Biden a renouvelé un outil à faire me à
aider Taïwan en cas où la Chine
rentrerait dans une guerre vis-à-vis de
l'île donc bon évidemment il est il n'a
plus autant de liberté je dirais que
avant la guerre de l'Ukraine merci
beaucoup Alain manque d'être venu ce
matin sur le plateau de Paris direct
j'envoie à votre ouvrage collectif
portrait d'un pays au bord de l'habille
auquel vous avez participé au Cherche
Midi fin du Congrès dimanche prochain on
suivra ça sur France 24 merci beaucoup